- [Narrator] Ladies and
gentlemen, boys and girls,
I present to you the world's
largest burrowing clam.
This is the geoduck.
And oh my God, it's an alien.
What the?
Oh my God, just look at it.
This is a geoduck.
And well, it looks like a, I guess, yeah.
Anyway.
The geoduck is a type of saltwater clam
that only comes from this
region in the pacific northwest.
They can burrow themselves
several feet underground,
which makes collecting
them a little difficult.
Isn't that right, Michael?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So when we're harvesting geoduck,
we use low pressure, high volume water.
The water comes in through the wand,
and then it makes the ground soft enough,
so you can stick your arm down three feet
to reach the neck of the
geoduck to pull it out.
The majority of the time
what you're looking for
is these guys sticking
up or these little holes
and that's how you know where they are.
- [Narrator] And viola, a geoduck.
- [Michael] This is the belly,
the softest part of the
meat of the geoduck.
This is the neck where the majority
of the meat comes from, the
two siphons are on the end
and they're kind of like
humans where, you know,
they're not all the same; it's
just everyone's different.
- [Narrator] The majority
of geoducks farmed here
will be sent to east Asia,
where they are a sought after delicacy.
But here in Seattle,
they're still a big deal
and nobody gets more excited
for geoduck than this guy.
So Tom, how do you prepare it?
- We have put it in chowders
in the past, from time to time,
but when you come in here to eat geoduck
at Taylor Shellfish,
you're gonna have it raw.
It's all about accentuating the freshness
of the geoduck chilled on the plate
with all those other
great fresh ingredients.
Prepared right, the texture of geoduck
is what really separates
it from everything else.
You think about it as having the sweetness
of the scallop, the saltiness of calamari,
and you have a really
excellent combination.
I love eating geoduck.
I'll just slice a bunch,
put it on a plate,
squirt a little lemon, throw some salt.
I couldn't ask for more.
- [Narrator] And now the most
important part, the taste.
Delicious.